okay well for people who are watching
this live stream we are doing kind of a
brainstorming meeting about
standardizing the way that game theory
is handled them of language and the
first thing we're trying to understand
is kind of a little bit of a map of what
we're trying to achieve and I think the
kind of as I understand it and maybe you
guys can um
can sort of correct me here the so the
first step would be considered to be
these one-shot games and that that's I
mean that some are that's the first set
of things and that leads us to things
like Nash equilibria and so on
and then kind of the next level would be
some kind of iterated games in which we
have a bunch more questions about having
strategies and so on is that so the fair
characterization or is that not correct
I mean their strategies in both but the
strategies and iterated games include
what the other players did in the past
but strategy applies to both so in some
sense the kind of the master function
for one-shot games if I'm not mistaken
that I just make sure I said this in the
right place um the let me just try to
understand one-shot games I think it
might be named strategic games cluster
strategy games fair enough but as
opposed to but I mean okay um normal
form games
okay so otherwise known okay but so a
name like normal form is of course
incomprehensible to anybody outside of a
field because just call them by name in
games it's sort of what okay but anyway
that the main point here is that the
main function that I think we're
interested in here is am I correct is
something like game soft does that make
sense well yes makes sense so where
there's some
pay off thing and there's some goal
which might be like a Nash equilibrium
or something um and then you are if I'm
if I'm not mistaken what we're basically
let's see if we have some information
here like we had this representation of
um so this would be an example if I'm if
I'm not mistaken where we're essentially
the and obviously there are many many
details here about whether we have
probabilities and continuous variables
and all sorts of things like this but
but let's walk through for for sake of
Jason and others what this means um if
I'm not mistaken this is kind of if this
was these are pure strategies these are
fewer strategies cooperate or defect on
pure strategies way we can define mix
strategies that is probability
distribution probability bution
on fewer strategies right I understand
but so the first step though is just to
understand the case where we're just the
minimal case here so this is this is
your nice demonstration um but what
we're not yet coming to probability
distributions because I want to it
because that's one different what we
have talked about I mean I mean it the
simplest case is you got some kind of
payoff matrix some kind of number of
players each is picking a pure strategy
and the outcome for each person is the
tuple in that part of the matrix where
the 3 chosen strategies or however many
chosen strategies intersect and it
specifies the payoff that each person
receives if that's the strategy choice
each person made right so that that in
for all simple one-shot game there's you
know from a design point of view you
made an interesting point there
implicitly so if we look at a function
that says for example minimize you know
I don't know X
plus y squared x and y what's that gonna
return ok so notice that what that did
was it returned two things it returned
what the minimum was and then it
returned the choices of x and y right
whereas in this proposed thing for game
solve we're actually not returning what
the payoff was we're merely returning
the the optimum is that correct
we're returning the analog of X 0 Y goes
to 0 and you could return both but what
he has here is can't game solve with the
in the Nash equilibrium being at both
defect is a it's like a result being
returned but right but so maybe what we
should think about from a design point
of view is the third argument here where
there is also the you know a property
type argument that determines what to
return sure so for example we could have
in my opinion we must return strategies
and we might my we may return also
payoffs form strategies for plays and
payoffs turnip
ok so fair enough zinc and no analogical
with minimize we return solutions and
the value of the optimal value of the
function in the case of games solve we
return strategies and also we attempt a
offs that corresponds closest to the
values of y or x and y variables here
and they and yeah right but which is
different so augment would be the analog
so the analog of augment would be to
return the fact effect for example the
analog minimized yes yes yes defend
effect and also were the result
or sales no I understand but but that's
not what if you're looking at the screen
right so we've got minimize here um and
minimizes returning boat so what I'm
suggesting which gets both cases right
is that we could return here either okay
so the default let's imagine okay let's
look at this so the default but we've
got many different if things to look at
here so the default case might be to
return just the strategy just the odd
thing okay now the next case might be to
return a list of but I'm not sure this
is correct
a list of strategy comma payoff right
and so there what we could do in that
case is we could do one of two things we
could either say one arrow defect , you
know 0.67 or something - arrow defect ,
you know 0.4 or which I think would be a
better thing to return we could return
for this we could return an association
even this is this is something that
we're increasingly doing where we say
strategy arrow and then we give this
Steven I do not understand you are
cooking about makes this is a strategy
she's just selling if we want outcome
vector and a and a payoffs outcome
vector as in an association so you can
look it up by saying what were the
strategies that were found by the solve
what would the payoff that were found by
the solves and in either case you can
ask for it by name instead of by
position that's all I'm talking about
we're not at mixed strategies yet we're
gonna we're gonna tackle mixed
strategies in a minute because I think
they're I'm just dealing with aa analog
of the return of minimized versus Arg
min okay that we might suggest from for
how to do this do the comments on this
Roger do you have a comment on this yes
so fro optimization we had three whereas
even min value as well
so there's two triple
so intimate so for optimization what are
the cases what are the things min value
oh I see I see I see the function min
value in there in those cases we didn't
do I think it's the proper thing to have
the third and you know to say what is
what property is if you want that I
think so because I don't this case it
makes more sense to have these as we did
it actually so it's not a bad design
because those are well established and I
agree because that part of a pipeline
whereas I think here the likelihood of
this being part of a pipeline is
considerably lost right okay so we're
going to talk about mixed strategies but
before we talk about mixed strategies I
want to talk for a minute about
iteration okay um okay because I think
iteration is gonna mix I think iteration
is going to force some aspects of this
design perhaps but before you get to
that I just want to mention one other
thing here right now you're talking
about game solve where you're asking for
it to find a Nash equilibrium right you
in principle could you know have other
things that you want to ask about a game
besides where it's Nash equilibria are
yes but such as I think we've already
listed some of these and I think Valerio
has some of these like best response we
can ask also about Max min solutions in
the case of game solve and also maybe
it's makes sense to have a function like
game so value about payoffs no but
that's what that's what we're dealing
with with the third argument we don't
need a separate function because we've
got a third argument that specifies what
I want to finish I think you're clear
even but the thing I want to point out
about goals right um there there are
some assumptions being built in here
about the kind of game that you have
like Nash equilibrium assumes that
you've got like simultaneous choice
right and that's one of the parameters
that these even one-shot games can have
is do the players choose their strategy
simultaneously in ignorance of each
other do the does one of the players go
first and the other player gets to react
to it there's different kinds of even
one
games in that respect I say so but but
wait a minute so we can think of this as
generalize yes if I'm / game types or
game and how we can get game features
game characteristics because this is
something you want as a solve right um
it can be specifications of the game
besides its payoff matrix like other
characteristic set but the number of
Dementor the rank of the matrix tells
you the number of players right but
there's there's other aspects of the
game like you know is it it is is it a
sequential game is it a what move order
is it a simultaneous choice game right
okay we could imagine for example an
option called game structure perhaps is
that reasonable I mean are these things
nameable or are they are they not
there's not that many of them there's
not move orders how much they can know
about the other person's payoffs okay
order of moves okay amount of knowledge
right about other other players payoffs
there's some other in some of the more
advanced games there's questions about
whether or not so this is figure at Nash
equilibrium for example this is more of
a property but you you can ask for
equilibria that besides Nash Nash means
only one player gets to change their
strategy you can ask for an equilibrium
that could be that if three players
could change their strategy at once for
example if various kinds of cooperation
or closed apology so isn't it if okay so
Nash equals only one player can change
it once is that right well a Nash
equilibrium is one where no player can
improve their or their performance
right if all the other people keep where
they are right yes yes but it might be
possible to for both of us to improve
our performance if we could agree that
we're both gonna do B and I say right
now surely one player makes is able to
make a check optimal with respect to
only one player being able to make a
change from what he as soon as the other
people are doing you know has been Max's
themselves but yes you're only
considering changes
that don't get to be strategic
cooperation between the players right so
you're saying Nash I mean it's basically
equilibrium with cooperation of some
kind
well Nash means the only one person gets
its you only one person can try to
change the strategy and if if no player
can unilaterally change what they're
doing and improve their performance
you're at a Nash equilibrium I get it
but so you're saying this summit form of
cooperative equilibrium where multiple
players can there's more there's more in
large and games with large numbers of
players there are you can have them you
know a minimum coalition setting you can
talk about it so that notion of Nash
equilibrium so Nash sounds like not that
Steven
no but it's a optimal with respect to
only one player making a change
alternative case okay and to be clear
nuclear in Nash you you do consider
overall players no player is able to
improve but each player only gets to try
to change what they're doing once it's
not a Nash equilibrium if there's one
player who can improve by unilateral
action so you do have to iterate over
each of the players not meter a you have
to counter each of the players to see if
any of them can improve their position
yeah but they can't acting alone right
whereas if you're allowed to form a
coalition to move to change your
strategies together
that's a stricter notion of an
equilibrium than a Nash equilibrium if
something is still in equilibrium in
that I guess I guess so for our purposes
I mean so you're defining various
different these sound like various
different goals for the guys I think
that we can say in Nash equilibrium
about satisfaction every player after
the game has the satisfactions it it is
not better it was not better strategy
for him to play right yes but the
question is its resolving goal to find
those that's right think about it is
that it's a solving goal right and there
are other goals you're saying
yes Jason which involve some kind of
cooperative equilibrium yes equilibrium
the Nash okay fine but but I'm what I
want to understand here is in the
parameterization of these things do you
have to say players a B and C can form a
coalition but D and E cannot and stuff
like that or is that you usually don't
you just talk about there's there's the
usual parameter is a shoes either Nash
one at a time or only n players can
collaborate or any number of players and
collaborate okay so so then we're gonna
need a parameterised version of this
right because as the name for the names
for a name for such game is non
cooperative games that is cooperation
it's not possible or it's not supposed
in such games right okay so what we
probably want to do is the goal the
simplest case of the goal is just
something like nash equilibrium but the
more complicated case of the goal is to
say is to have a whole association which
includes cooperation move order perhaps
we can put it in there maybe yeah and if
you want to make this as general as
possible even things like whether or not
you know the other person's payoffs and
you're choosing your strategy because
they're they're very old versions of
this which even precede formal game
theory where you weren't allowed to know
the other person's I also you only got
to see what they were doing
this is like an 19th century economics
but that's a kind of a degenerate form
from the standpoint of right I like this
from a design point I mean what we're
trying to do here is we're trying to get
the big picture of the design and then
we will worry about how its implemented
and things like it but but what you're
basically saying is that the goal
structure you know there's a simple I
just want the Nash equilibrium and then
there's a more complicated let's
characterize exactly what we're trying
to get out of the thing but that sounds
like constraints rather than goals
they're not simply constraints I mean
because the characterization of the kind
of equilibrium that you found well okay
so
whether we call it goals I mean there's
a sort of objectives what we're trying
to solve for yes um
that's sort of what we're talking about
here I think are are you allowed to
cooperate or not it sounds like some of
those can be the thing about cooperation
or not is some of those can be thought
of as characteristics of the game itself
and others can be thought of as
characteristics of the solutions that
you're looking for right right so you
can little goals it's the game wish no
cooperation is possible at all in which
case that perimeter doesn't matter right
that's just it restricting the kind of
right that's what I'm saying it's it's
the constraints it's restricting right
okay so look look in some cases right
okay so we've got two different things
here um you know feature of the game or
feature of the desired solution that's
right
that's right and that's and I'm afraid
that will hang us at some point if we do
this wrong and and arguably the best way
to handle this is to have a second
argument that is simply that could break
those apart if necessary in the
Association that would be my suggestion
given that these are fairly close we
could potentially have you know to me
like the payoff matrix looks like the
objective function in a regular
optimization and yes yes but but Roger I
mean one of the questions from the point
of view of design
okay so so another form of design so
there will be an alternative design in
which the way it works is to say game
solve of payoff
you know arrow or payoff matrix arrow
blah blah blah and then constraint one
you know constraint arrow blah blah blah
those those constraints might be just
that can you cooperate I understand that
so my question is
Roger my question is really it's simply
a question do you try and puff out the
specification in the first argument that
was previously just to pay off matrix
and put some of this other information
there or do you put it in the second
argument as a what to solve for type
thing right and and the question is is
there a bright line between a
specification quotes of the game this is
a specification of the desired solution
or are those two things kind of do they
smoosh into each other right okay and my
I mean I don't know this field as you
guys well know but but as I'm listening
to you guys it seems to me and I'm not
certain whether there's a bright line
distinction between those two things I
think they can sufficient to each other
I think people think about them both
ways round and they try to distinguish
sets of things are solving for by
classifying characters the game itself
okay so problem okay so that's that
suggests probably all this stuff or in
the second argument I would agree
leaving the first argument is a fairly
pure payoff matrix yes I think that
that's right - okay um all right so
let's can we make a little look forward
before we come back to mixed strategies
let's have a little look forward to
iterated games
Stephen I propose to return to mean in
minimize and to do an analogy to games
in minimize we may have two functions
one for every player x squared plus y
squared and the second function by a
function for the second play and we hope
we can favor as argument x and y we can
have also the descriptions of strategy
sets and so it's an analogy between game
solve and minimize will in game sell
soul we may have
two functions one function for every
player and also we have the same number
of arguments strategy and the strategy
says strategy says might be constraints
him game soul and about cooperate in the
case of this example of a prisoner's
dilemma we must understand that
cooperate do not mean that this is a
cooperation game mutually cooperate they
do not have between talks and the
contrary right and it's just a name for
that strategy it's just it's not yes I
want to understand what you said about
yes we may choose minimize one payoff
function 1 x squared plus y squared and
the second the payoff function may be X
X by a plus y simply so we have payoff
function after that we must describe
strategies of the player place so we
have X the strategy of first player and
for this strategy we must describe the
strategy sets so we can write X in X
element of yes yes yes yes
where x SI x is strategy set and the
be defined also as constraints it's
usually not so defined am traditional
textbooks or monographs
but we can do such description also for
the second player we can describe each
his strategy and why why why yeah I
understand what you're saying is is this
some nonlinear generalization of the
traditional method minimize game so as a
formal formal abstraction which in a
realization extension of minimize but in
a sum I think you can often see it as as
you maximizing some variables and
minimizing some in the about minimize so
one play my only minimize a partially
his payoff function because he has only
[Music]
inference only his variable or strategy
only as example first play my inference
only x squared
he can't influence y skirt this is
difference between minimize traditional
optimization and the game see worried
optimization is if we can say should oh
every player can partially optimize his
new function and there's a
all can they influence all the functions
at all okay let me just try to
understand the so first question the you
know the existing structure for game
solve proposed in this way is what's
being said here that mean that this is a
not that I mean that this is not the
most general possibility because you can
have an arbitrary function rather than
having the standard linear algebra type
minimization is there's at the point
here it's sort of I mean what he's
saying is that the the payoffs don't
have to be in the form of a of a an N by
n by n payoff matrix where people are
choosing you know an equal number of
strategies each you can have one player
can choose that this variable lies
between this range and this range
another player chooses that this very
wise and so forth and the point is if
you generalize that form then the then
the function that determining payoffs
might not simply be a you know extract
which column vector from the from payoff
matrix it might be a more general
function than that that ties together
the strategy choices of the players so
the point he's making is that the the
way in which that the simple form the
the von Neumann form is that you just
have an N by n by n whatever matrix and
people are just selecting rows and
columns out of it and and the
intersection of all their choices is one
cell and that and the payoffs are list I
guess I get it right this famous U is
coming up to some extent in the mixed
strategy case because in the mixed
strategy case you don't just have a
single you know you've you've got um
some like interval of possibilities and
things like this power distribution over
your strategy set that's right right so
what you're saying is so okay so let's
let's understand what this means from a
I mean in in the standard way we do
things we have solve and we have reduce
right and these are things that give us
different you know in one case we are
trying to nail down the minimal well in
the case of solver trying to get the
generic result
case of reduce we're trying to get
something more complicated I don't know
that's analogous here I mean I think you
want a form that allows a simple matrix
and understands it as the in linear I'm
in form but you probably also want to
have a more complex functional form
where this bus station next case is
functional specification of payoffs I so
so I want to make another point about
the strategy so that this this way of
listing you know each of the players you
know as a dimension so to speak their
strategies that can't get more
complicated when you're when you're
talking about end players of uniform
strategy choices right I mean this if
you've got two or three dimensions and
they have very different controls this
way of specifying us what you want to do
it but if you're trying to say I'm not
doing a twenty player game and they all
have the same strategy sets but this is
the functional format okay so the next
case is compressed Saturday array form
would be an N rank tensor that's right
in place right okay so hold on a second
compressed array form of payoff matrix
of payoff tensor basically so one case
one case is the flattened you know
outcome arrow value basically outcome
one our value one right and where each
outcome is a complete outcome right the
other would be the the other is a is a
know you know and and a rank n array
rank n tensor basically reckon array in
which um right I'm not quite sure how
you label that howdy she was a quick
question are you talk about the outcome
you're talking about the specification
or the matrix of the payoff format so
I'm specifying the payoff matrix here so
what I'm saying is in this case
obviously this thing is really much more
elaborate than it needs to be right
because they're in fact the only
information here is a matrix crammed
there actually it's two matrices here
it's a it's a tensor that's a 2x3 matrix
with the two that took a pair at each
point right right so it's a 2 by 2 by 2
creature yes but in general it's an N by
n by n creature is if all the players
have the same number of strategy traces
each
yes I see ok ok ok if different numbers
of choices and their strategy sets then
you could it could have n by n by the
only only the only the payoffs at the
bottom have to equal the number of
players in the lowest rank of the 10 yes
you have to pay off every person that's
the only constraint on the form so n by
n by s but the S is it does it have to
be a full array or can it be a ragged
creature it might be n by M by K ok and
so there's the N is not the people it's
the number of strategies yes yes that's
right so strategies of player 1 may be
strategies 1 times strategies - mumbles
cities yeah right n strategies 1 by x n
strategies - and then there's very last
one is the number of players and only
it's a number of plays right ok the last
one has to be equal to the number of
total things you have in the previous
multiplication right no no strategies -
and strategies n number of strategies of
player M ok well so my question is is
this an array where it is a genuine
array that is essentially a rectangular
object you know or does the does this
last index have a different range for
different choices of the first two
indices but the last index has to have a
dimension that is equal to the number of
things in front of it
if it's n by n then the last ones to its
in by n by T then it's 3 n by n by s
sorry n by N by n by n by T then I see
ok so this can be an arbitrary rank okay
fine so we we need to know what this
looks like and if there is labeling on
it um we need to know how that labeling
works right so there's there is a raw
array there's a raw I mean this is
probably a data set basically it's it's
an association right thing was just a
little bit simplifying though about this
I mean in the most general form some of
these things can be complicated strategy
sets but normally it's just you know a
number between 1 and n and there's no
other differentiation between them if
you're talking about the actual matrix
formulas best payoff matrix it isn't in
a functional form there the then the
strategy sets are you know just range n
um okay well alright but so look one of
the sub branches here is to work out
what this compressed array form of the
payoff tensor looks like right that's
just well I just mean okay the array
form of the as opposed to as a polling
in all cases in a list what I'm saying
Roger yeah I mean this is we've got a
bunch of functions that do this okay so
and this functional specification of
payoffs
let me just let's just address that for
a second and I really want to go on to
iterated games because I think that's
going to inform how we do some of this
other stuff um the UM okay so um
actually there's a question on the live
stream about board games and things like
that suite could you find the summer
school projects about chess and about
card games
even-steven I was to write a simple
example as free players okay the first
play it has have has reached for
strategies
second has five strategies and safely
has two strategies and to write the
payoffs of such games payoffs of every
player and so we have a clear image of
why that's fine yeah okay so so you're
saying but that we're talking now about
the M equals three
okay so let's actually write out what
the thing is so one thing we have in the
standard way of doing this what we would
have here is um
so let's look offer players it's a set
of place it may be number one number two
number three number one for first player
number two for the second player number
three for the said player yeah I
understand okay but every player's one
two three okay for play one we may say
about the number of each of his
strategies well let's call them for our
purposes here we just call them s1 s2 s3
or something strategies to same number
of players so just are you trying to
write out this structure for that case
is that the point I was thinking we
should just do the array just just
symbolically okay all right tell me what
the array looks like so well actually do
you want to do the unrolled case first
or the array case first
do you read case first okay so tell me
what it should say Jason do you can just
do it with array to forget way to
generate it yeah I understand but I'd
like to talk about the prisoner's
dilemma case okay because what I think
the prisoner's dilemma case to two
players two strategies each and because
there's two players two
number is two so you have two strategies
means the first thing is to and the
second thing is to and the fact there's
two players means that there's two at
the bottom of the tensor it's that
that's the yes that's the case right so
that's the you know that's eg prisoner's
dilemma yeah any any two player two
strategy game okay however I would like
to point out that this does not contain
the labeling we need to I'm saying
so that doesn't say that right right now
here it's fine but we've got strategies
one and two yeah it's not stored in it
right right now it's just purely
positional right so what I'm saying is
we need a way so which level of this
tensor is the names of strategies it's
the bottom level of the tensor isn't it
no the bot the top levels of the
translators are the strategies the
different players and the bottom level
is the payoffs okay but but so if we
were going to decorate this if we
wouldn't intense one layer of this into
a in table form and put in labels so we
can see it actually table some castles
yeah okay you take that array and now
let's look at table headings yes
and so then then it would be strategies
one come on strategies to come a payoff
that wasn't very helpful why didn't it
show the table headings okay so maybe
the lengths don't match no this is oh
look
right right yes yes so what are we
actually trying to do here
they need to be sub-lists you know today
so what do the sublists need to be you
tell me what what is this shotty two in
each okay so string there should be two
things okay so what are those things so
the top level is what player 1 choice
attract you want a shredder t2 okay so
okay so that one is basically let's
write it in a very um player is one I
doubt that that will work the
Association you think strategy is fine
it'll just uh and the strategy is that
that's strategy is one yeah we're a
whatever yeah okay so that's one case so
now the next case is its I mean we can
obviously do this programmatically but
let's just do it like this so this case
here is player is one or player is two
virus - priority is to stop okay so next
level is just placed level it's the same
thing but for player - okay and the
third level is what payoff
player 1 and player payoff for player 2
no no foreplay see I proposed to we're
doing the 2 2 by 2 case ok ok payoff
function no no no level the third level
is a name has to be denied in a Cell
it's the lowest level the tensor it's
what you're looking for yes yes that's
right that's what I'm looking for so it
will be cooperating and whatever it is
it's the that's the name of the
strategies that's the worst
lowest level in cancer the lowest level
the tensor is the payoff of player 1 for
that for that set of choices yeah two
for that set of flavors pay off pay off
two one or pay off everyone okay pay off
two one pay off to - yes okay all right
huh that's unimpressive oh here is your
your array actually the right thing
just want my arrays the wrong shape but
it's close ah there we go there you go
okay yep all right okay so now okay so
it's pretty clear how we generalize this
it's pretty clear this is we can see
that what we have to do if there are
three strategies for player one will
have a three by two by two array etc etc
this this makes it fairly clear how we
have to generalize it agree so the only
issue here is that there is a need for
labeling like this that we need to think
through okay but let's not deal with
that right now okay we're not if there's
something quick to say about functional
specifications we could say that now I
was I really want to go to iterated
games because I think that's what's
going to yeah that's graduated okay fine
so let's talk about so what does it mean
um you know I mention before I yeah go
ahead anything it's gonna be interested
instead of having a single strategy for
each player you're gonna have a strategy
vector for each player for an n number
of moves of the game more T number of
moves of the game right they're gonna
have a different one a different element
of their strategy set at each of the of
the of the steps of the game up to up to
T right and that's the specification of
their move vector and they get a payoff
for each step of the game and the other
accumulative payoff for all the steps of
the game right and then the issue with
strategies is that in general their next
their strategy on later moves could
depend upon their moves and other
players move you're specifying the
actual the actual game instance as
opposed to game you're playing but the
game instance is and is a move vector
for each player okay question in the
workflow so I was I as I mentioned two
guys I ran into Bob Axelrod a couple of
weeks ago who was pushing who is very
much in iterative games fellow and
was asking him about what people
actually do with iterated games and I
guess one of the questions that I have
is you know is there in fact so just
just to lay it out there right and I'm
confused by this is it the case that
there is a you know game solve is a kind
of game optimization and is there a
different thing that people do with
iterated games yes yes
you know iterated games players know
about the result of precedent right I
understand undecided what people are
trying to achieve but there is an
analogue thing for optimization it's
called dynamic optimization and that's
when you do many steps to term saying
sorry there's no terms it's the time
dimension and when I have a discount on
it and you have the infinite time case
or the yes sure if you have it if you
have a long time case you have a
discount factor on at the infinite time
case is a large discount factor can be
approximated by a finite game and so
forth but there's there's all kinds of
complexity and the way that you lay out
the time dimension and then in terms of
field strategy is just as they can have
pure or mixed strategies in a one-shot
game you could have pyramix strategies
in a iterated game and the strategy you
next may depend upon your whole past
move vector the opponent's whole past
move actor past me vector those was only
a finite look back in terms of number of
moves before you can consider and so ok
ok ok there's lots of help but what the
thing I want to understand first is the
overall workflow like in the case of
game solve for one-shot game I think I
understand that the overall workflow is
an attempt to find out for all the
various players in the game what is some
kind of optimal point but is it not the
case that with iterated games there is a
different workflow that is also of
interest that is more like essentially
just running the iterated game as
opposed to trying to find it so games
alters games simulate right just run
this game with players having this
strategy or this strategy choice
mechanism and you can do that in the
one-shot case - it's just your game
simulator is really simple you put in
one move for each guy's and you evaluate
the state of the game issue a set of
payoffs but but get game simulate okay
game so it's different from game solve
okay that's what I thought okay so is it
the case that there is a game solve
should it be is it analogous is it
directly analogous to game solve is the
iterated game solve directly analogous
to game to game solve only in certain
cases that are particularly simple okay
so you're saying I mean clearly there's
a lot more hair that you need to specify
for iterated game solve yes but there
are there are there are games that are
purely solvable by backwards induction
methods or by national methods even
though they're iterated right especially
a finite iterated game right there Nash
equilibria and I'm trying to get the
overall workflow here so the question is
there is a so one quote one case is
simulating iterated game but for
instance in optimization they're things
like dynamic programming from Pellman
yeah and it doesn't mean since you can
in principle solve it and if it's all
approximate you can really solve it
right but I'm just asking I want to
understand the overall workflow what
you're trying to achieve no but what I'm
saying is that then you can give the
whole solution to the end that's the
point sometimes you want a solution
sometimes you want a simulation
depending upon how simple the thing is
that you're simulating it might have
findable solutions or might not have
findable solutions right but there are
times when game solve makes sense on an
iterated game and there's but there's
lots of other things you want to do is
that you want to simulate it as well as
potentially stall to get in so I guess
that's what I'm you do want to simulate
it yes you do want to seem it so even if
you come up with some optimal strategy
you want to compared it to sort of a
different way of arriving at the
strategy
the other the other complexity here is
is you know
what what is the optional strategy can
depend upon the assumptions about the
people you're playing against and so you
know there's all kinds of other things
that go on once you're talking about
actual iterated games and people care
about them there's a population that
you're playing him against I understand
so for example for example if you know
that player one has a certain strategy
right then your strategy then you might
want to optimize over the strategies for
player 2 given a known strategy for
player 1 so the classic example of this
is you know when people looked at rules
with different look backs they
originally thought the tit-for-tat doing
what the other guy didn't last an
iterated prisoner's dilemma was an
optimal strategy and then they
discovered that if the rules were
restricted to only look back one they
were too stupid to learn from
tit-for-tat and permanent retaliation
works better than tit for tat because
the rules are so stupid they don't adapt
to being taught by different eyes right
yes so it depends upon how sophisticated
the strategies are that can be adopted
by the people you're playing against
what's the optimal strategy is for you
right so because they want to be able to
consider it things like that you want to
be able to simulate and you want to be
able to game solve under you know it's
actually constraints it's it's game
requirements the strategies have to be
from this set the the solutions can't
look back longer than this the game
doesn't go on longer than this there's
various kinds of constraints you can put
on it to make something ok but but but
fundamentally in this iterated game
optimize the result is a function that
tells you what to do right it's gonna
tell you it's gonna tell you strategy
sets to the players that meet the
criteria that you sacked right which we
do which could be that this is a an
optimal strategy against this other
player set or that this is a Nash
equilibrium of all of these strategies
or that this is you know you're gonna
ask different questions yeah but I'm
trying to understand a different issue
right in the case in the in the game
solve case that we had up here the
fundamental answer
at least in the pure-strategy case we'll
talk about the mixed-strategy case later
right the fundamental answer is a
particular strategy or a set of snow
it's a satyr strategy it's a strategy
for each player and a payoffs for each
player
well we only returned the payoff we're
not returning the payoff but I
understand but I don't think that meet
the criteria that you asked for like
that they're a Nash equilibrium yes I
get it but what I'm trying to understand
in the iterated case it seems like what
you often want is to learn is to come up
with a black box function that given
certain characteristics of the game will
be I mean that's much more like a
control systems problem I think where
you're trying to get a black box
function which given the characteristics
of what's happening in the game will
somehow optimize things for you is that
correct the only problem with that is
before you aspect of it you're okay but
I mean it doesn't it so if you're asking
for a for you what you're effectively
doing is you're fixing characteristics
the other players
you're letting one of the players
various strategy and you're asking what
he can optimize right by doing is that
right there's a whole set of questions
like that sure in questions I understand
so there's different there's different
criteria but the fundamental thing from
a workflow point of view that you want
out of this if I'm not mistaken is a
function which when given a thing you
might I think thing you want out is a
function which one given the history of
the game tells you what to do next not
necessarily I mean that that's a
strategy rule and you might want that as
an input or you might want that as an
output I understand I understand that
input when you simulate it could even be
an input when you're solving yeah I
guess you know you know some stuff you
know some players strategy but the
output you want is find me a strategy
which is somehow optimal given the
things that I know I understand my point
is that strategy that is optimal might
just be a move vector it might not be a
formula that looks at the past and tell
you what to do next
it might just be do these moves for the
next you know this actual list of your
point is okay and that's the case we're
in the one shot game that's all you have
Steven you can look at such game as one
shot games we can look if the number of
iterations are infinite you can look at
these iterations strategies as sequence
and we must find limit and the of such
payoffs may be sums of payoffs but in
such case there is a multiplier that
tends to zero
scandalous could be a discount rate and
so on
make sense for such game such infinite
games to has to have a solution but in
the case when we have a finite number of
iteration it in my opinion it's not so
interesting because we have a vector and
we can look at the such game also as a
one-shot game
yeah but for a long sequence right at
one shot with a huge number of strategy
the point is making is it yes you could
think of eight choices of 1 and 0 as
being one choice of 2 to the 2 to the 8
possibilities of course yes right so
civilly in such case is more developed
in for sequences infinite sequences but
for finite sequence sequences there is a
lot of so named experimental games
is also a branch of them she were a
branch of experimental games for
experimental games there are a lot of
interesting results that looks not so
good as in theory look so okay I want to
understand I'm trying to understand the
workflow of what people wants here right
I'm trying to say that I think that for
games simulate you want to have the idea
that there's an output which is just a
set of actual choices of moves for the
different players the different steps of
the game right and I also heard along
the way that's kind of like just the
it's just the the Ness list or the fold
listed version of of of what you had for
the one shot and it's leaving behind a
trail of states of all the choices
people made right and it's it's just
those new vendors that object is the
game instance right of the choices were
made these move vectors were put in at
the different stages and and you can ask
characteristics of it like you know
what's the sum of the payoffs of all the
players
right so it's an impossible way to be to
have a game solve lists so game solve is
the one-shot case and game solve list I
don't know if this is right but that
will be a possibility or iterated game
solve right in but before you even get
to the solve you just want to have the
thing which is the instance right you
want to have the data object which is
the instance itself which would be game
evolve list or something like that but
it's it's it's not necessarily solving
or optimizing anything yet it's just
this this particular set of moves with
this original payoff matrix right the
character nataline by in a set of
characteristics why what okay tell you
why because it's the next move Jason
how'd how do you pick the next
move this is my point you can either
have it be something which is laid down
in advance you choose your whole mood
vector or you can have it be something
which is a function of the previous
moves those are two different ways of
arriving at a strategy choice right but
if it's laid down in advance there's no
evolution happening it's just the
evolution the evolution in that case is
just a set of payoffs that occur right
but my point is you you want to think of
the other strategy choice things as ways
of specifying every player's move vector
I think we can return now to treat him
as dilemma there a lot of competition
for such games iterative games iterated
prisoner's dilemma and for such game one
of winning strategies is do so as you're
opening in the precedent iteration to
protec we know yeah such cases as a type
of strategies so trying to understand if
in that case let's take take the
tit-for-tat behavior in the iterated
prisoner's dilemma okay yes the what we
want so one function that we want is
something that just says you know do
tit-for-tat yes so what happens right
right so yes we were doing some of these
game three experiments and some of the
previous projects right we would have a
data structure which had the move
vectors different players laid down and
then we would have a function like a
rule that determines what you should do
next and that could be specified by you
have you could only have a look-back
list of this far of your own and the
other guys and then you can look at all
the possibilities and tit for tat is
just the one that you know has for the
all the different possible look back one
things it just happens to pick its next
move like the coloring of the CA rule by
only what the other person did last
right that's but that's just up in all
possible combinations of
your moves and the other guys moves as
far back as you have that right arrow I
do one right or I do zero I do what he
did um but that's that's just like a CA
rule you can have a dependence on any of
its predecessors right you just specify
the rule that way but that specification
of the rule it's different from the
actual sequence of the most of the game
it's just what's determining the
sequence moves a game I get it I think
but but what I'm saying is you could
imagine something where at every step
you effectively do a game solve with a
certain goal that's one possible way of
doing this it's not the same as tit for
tat tit for tat it's doing something you
know it's a particular strategy that
yours the whole game solving thing sure
doesn't look ahead at all you know it
looks back right right so but that what
I'm trying to understand again let's go
through this again
okay the output that I want here I would
assume is given a game history right yes
maybe some of the payoffs and every
iteration well but what I want is
something which says okay fundamentally
what this wants to say is you know
whatever it's called game iterate games
simulate whatever I think game iterate
is the right term soldier but player one
their strategy function they have a
strategy function that gets to look at
certain kinds of things and player 2 has
a also has a strategy function right and
these strategy functions are looking
back they can look at a bunch of
different stuff they're fed a bunch of
different things and then what game
iterate has here is some kind of history
vector if I'm not mistaken and its
result is a next move based on those
strategies is that right
well I mean it didn't have to be an
extra move if she's got the functions
and you have the past moves you can just
put it in there and do as many steps as
you want right fine one strategy may be
too sure but that's fine that's just
what the function what these strategy
functions do so it could be anything I
mean this is this is basically seven
okay so this would be game iterate list
effectively this would start from a net
and then give you move one move to etc
annan it could be something that is more
than one it could be a little piece of
frozen history just like nest list yes
and have can look at multiple if I
remember how this works we have a nest
um what is the function that can look
back more um necklace necklace doesn't
need to look back more for some reason
but nest wireless does need to look back
more right so this would be like nest
list um I can have a longer Annette
vector that right I mean this is the
basic workflow here and I don't
understand the difference between this
function and what is special about this
being a game theory function as opposed
to just you know yeah why is this a game
theory function I mean until you put
constraints on how it what the [ __ ] that
function takes it's not pretty early
game 300d it's it's just the way of
generating a vector there can be
interpreters move after and fed egg sort
of game pair of matrices but the only
thing that makes it a game function is
the fact that that function cares about
the content so this payoff matrices
right yes I mean otherwise it's just a
general function that's just doing
that's right um I unfortunately
to go fairly soon and we'll have to
continue this different time but but um
I actually feel like we're getting we're
getting going pretty well here um I'd
like to understand I shared some
questions from our live stream which I'd
like to address here um there's a bunch
of discussion here about adversarial
learning games
um there's questions about board games
um I think there's this we did you know
there was some nice projects at the at
the summer school that involved um yeah
so this was an example of a card game
and a specification that this is worth
us looking at okay because this was a
specification of a card game and I'm
making sense with a things like a game
tree and so on making sense and this has
the this has in the case of iterated
games it looks that we do not have three
of the games but you could have a tree I
mean you said random we could but it's
my opinion more simple we describe a
one-shot game game iterate has
description of one fruit game after this
we may describe the number we can give
the number of iteration and we can give
also strategy for iterated games
strategies like tit-for-tat sure but we
want to be able to give a general
strategy but the red point here is yes
yes yeah the difference here is one is a
random variate or something like it um
this game this game we're saying in
front of us right this is a different
kind of thing it's a game with a game
state and a tree of that it passes
through Trias traits that are passed
through based upon the the player moves
whereas the iterated game setup the only
effect or the past is to control what
players can
choose next if their strategy depends
upon the past and the payoffs that they
get but the payoffs they're getting is a
per move thing that's just accumulating
either adding or with a discount
function but there's no evolving game
state like there is in an example in
front of you right in the example in
front of you you've got a different
abstraction of what a game is that the
game has a game state and the choice of
strategy changed the game state you're
trying to reach and they're only payoffs
at n states of the game so that's it
that's a different I so what you're
saying so in the case of the game theory
we're talking about
there is no useful game state except
there is a move made by each player I
don't quite understand there is some
game state because there's a move made
by the game state it resolves to a
payoff at each step and then yes and
that's the only effect of the of each
the only effect of each round of the
iteration is a payoffs experienced by
all players for that step of it and
whatever influence that and their past
races have on their future choices but
it has no other ongoing recorded state
that the players are controlling your
example this example is related for
extensible game theory as a branch of
game see where there are a lot of
results and the contribution so ok but
this is but but your point is ok and
this is relevant its function because we
can experiment with such function we can
simulate it I understand but the issue
here is and and on our live stream there
questions about relationship to game
simulators used in machine learning for
example and the notion of you know
reinforcement learning strategies and so
on right what relationship they have
together
that's and that's closure the form of
game the extent extended form of game
because what they're doing in those
cases with the reinforcement learning
things and these are actually hooking up
an AI to the game controller of a
scrolling video game for example and
they're try
to teach it what to do in the game by
how well or poorly it does right
so in that case they're using a game
which has a state and not just local
payoffs to train the AI to move the
controls of the game right yeah the long
form extended form game like this and
then they're giving the feedback to the
AI of you know you can lose new
controllers around all these ways and
fly through the simulator as many times
as you like and try to learn what works
and what doesn't work in it right which
is a different use case is that there's
it that needs that needs the the
implantation of an idealization of a
game with state not a one-shot payoffs
game with the of the Norman Morgan form
organ thought-form right well so that's
interesting because we need to
understand okay so we need to understand
the correspondence between these it's
very interesting to use machine learning
in the case of iterated a games but in
my opinion it will not have good results
okay I mean look okay what's the okay
just a minute let me just write down
just so we have notes for next time
relationship to other stuff um and one
one thing we have is a machine learning
and reinforcement learning extended form
games games with state yes so there's
games with state um you know machine
learning reinforcement learning we've
also got the relationship which I don't
understand to control theory right so in
that case what you want is to that move
function you say and it's a feedback
function of state okay note yet
is what the controller is is that
function that tells you what to do next
depending on the state so for instance
when when we have in all that stuff we
were talking about without we knows and
God knows what else when we've got that
just tell me what function to look up
here Roger what function should I look
up to just linear quadratic in you could
headache design what is it called LQG
well isn't it what about our friendly
Kalman filter well that it's but it's
harder to explain there it is okay
linear quadratic what is it yeah lq
regulator yes that sounds about right
okay design using state space models
okay I know nothing about this stuff
okay so if you pick this lq regulated
gains for instance okay so the way that
that for Doozers for linear systems and
the objective that you want to minimize
is a is an integral of a kradic that
measures the error of what the goal is
for you okay and if that turns out and
it's an infinite time horizon in that
case what comes back is that the optimal
controller or player if you like we'll
have a a it's just a linear function of
your state okay so that's what the games
are it it comes back
those are question because this matrix
have anything to do with the game payoff
matrices we probably her idea
no well wait in indirectly but if you
open it up I hope I can't remember what
this notes say this was answer is there
is a correspondence to the to the right
to it cost assess the cost function
that's the payoff yeah
integral with a cell yes okay that's
that's the payoff I mean that's that's -
it's that's what you want to minimize
okay
and that's similar to wanting to
maximize the payoff function of your
iterated player or your iterated game
with an infinite number of moves right
no tiny variations of this like if you
want to do it of a finite time horizon
it doesn't come out there's a constant
in your function like that it's gonna
bury that's when you solve in that
particular case you you get a ricotta so
so hold on a second so what we've got
here
you know reinforcement learning control
theory and um you know solution of
iterated games seem like they are
related
they're absolutely Raymond yep yes yes
yeah in this case one way did you see
your adversary for instance is as noise
those are things that act on the system
it's like another player but you can't
control what they do so the wind that
blows on your airplane it's gonna blow
on that airplane and you can't control
it okay so in control theory
hey you quotes player is often an
external stochastic right so for
instance for your heating system at home
Stephen you can't control how many
people walk in the room everyone is
about 65 watts um you know you correct I
thought it was 50 watts is it so it
probably depends on how right this might
be 50 okay okay but that's a variation
it's just a cassock you can't control it
mhm or how much Sun shines on it -
e-rate okay but you can statistically
say something about it but you cannot
exact the surface to do say anything
about right and then there's two ways
you can look at that you can think about
what's gonna be the likelihood or
expectation of the noise it's gonna be
coming in and that's one way and the
other is you can say what's the worst
thing that can happen which is if you
imagine that that random environmental
vector where a player trying to break
your system yes and I said okay the
hostile player and the worst environment
are equivalent right I see
either look at statistical expectations
or oh yeah and all of that happens in
culture it's just we don't have
functions for all this we have sort of
the simple very production you know all
of these other things are there - and
are used in fact this I don't think
necessarily we have the right people in
its meeting to know this but for in the
case of modern machine learning and
reinforcement learning are they that can
you compare that to these things they're
very similar because that's yes that
noise vector is that other player and
they use updating and they use updating
schemes that are that are very it very
much comes from what's called dynamic
control or optimal control yeah okay so
Saul the Wiener
control theory stuff well I don't think
so
you said about noise this is nature in
such type of mathematical models are
only decision-making the problems we
must have another two at least two
rational playing that inference system
in such game the case whichever game we
know that but the idealization that
people were doing is for control three
two is they imagine that they as a
controller or one player and they
imagine that a hostile environment is
like an enemy player trying to break
their system and that's a way of
thinking of making their system robust
against the worst things that the random
environment can throw at them they just
they treat the random environment as a
hostile player and they end out with an
intelligence that might not have to
stress test their suspect so one thing
I'd like to understand here and I really
need to go then is is you know we are
starting to work on you know Gans
another sort of different sort of
interaction structures for machine
learning right and to me there seems to
be an analogy I'd like to make sure that
we have a similar structure I mean
because for example we've also got you
know the whole active classification
business and so on yep recurrent they
weren't neural networks and this stuff
are gonna be very very close all right
so we have to think about active
classification um all right well okay
very very useful guys we're making
progress we're not there yet
I think we need to we need to tackle
this iterated stuff more carefully and
we also need to look at the horrifying
case of mixed strategies um which I
claim is going to be that the reason I'm
pushing on the iterative case right is I
think the mixed strategies are going to
be a special case of what we need to do
for the iterated case because I claim
the mixed strategy is gonna wind up
being you know some essentially random
variates or something it's not really
around and variate it's really a
distribution but it's it comes from it's
a random variate coming anyway never
mind it's the same but there are Ganesha
but the other thing to realize in the in
the game context is that there's an
extra reason to use a bit strategy in a
game context which is to make yourself
less predictable to the other player so
that's the thing which is different
about choosing a mixed strategy in a
competitive context amount of time in
poker because it makes the other player
less get less information every time you
bet um okay
very useful guys to be continued
hopefully we can continue this soon
making progress okay yeah thanks okay
okay
see you bye